THAT YOU DO EVERY DAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
LIZA BILLINGS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> KYLE RITTENHOUSE IS SET TO
GO ON TRIAL NEXT WEEK FOR
MURDER.
THE TEENAGER KILLED TWO PEOPLE
IN KENOSHA, WISCONSIN DURING
PROTESTS LAST YEAR IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE JACOB MAKE
POLICE SHOOTING.
NOW, WHAT HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE
PAYING ATTENTION THIS MORNING IS
A PRETTY CONTROVERSIAL DECISION
BY THE JUDGE IN A PRETRIAL
HEARING AS THERE WERE SOME
GROUND RULES SET THAT THE
PROSECUTION IS NOT HAPPY WITH.
>> VICTIM IS A LOADED, LOADED
WORD.
AND I THINK ALLEGED VICTIM IS A
COUSIN TO IT.
LET THE EVIDENCE SHOW WHAT THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS.
AND IF THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
ANY OR MORE THAN ONE OF THESE
PEOPLE WERE ENGAGED IN ARSON,
RIOTING OR LOOTING, THEN I'M NOT
GOING TO TELL THE DEFENSE THEY
CAN'T CALL THEM THAT.
.
>> OKAY.
"EARLY START" LAURA JARRETT
JOINS US.
LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENED
THERE.
PEOPLE SAY KYLE RITTENHOUSE
KILLED -- THEY CANNOT BE CALLED
VICTIMS, THE PEOPLE THAT HE
KILLED.
THEY CAN BE CALLED RIOTERS AND
LOOTERS.
>> THAT'S THE PART THAT PEOPLE
ARE CALLING SO DISTURBING.
THE PROSECUTION IS CALLING IT A
DOUBLE STANDARD.
THEY'RE DEAD.
THEY CANNOT DEFEND THEMSELVES.
WHEN THERE IS AN AGREEMENT THAT
SOMEBODY HAN HARMED, IN SOME WAY
INJURED OR KILLED, VICTIM IS AN
ACCEPTABLE TERM.
COURTS ARE SPLIT ON THIS.
JURY INSTRUCTIONS USE THE TERM
VICTIM ALL THE TIME.
SOME PEOPLE DEFINE IT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
BUT WHAT IS PLAYING OUT, THE
JUDGE TOOK IT A STEP FURTHER.
SAYING THE PEOPLE WHO DIED
SHOULD BE CAST IN THE LIGHT OF
THE CRIMES THEY COMMITTED.
IF YOU'RE THE PROSECUTOR IN THE
CASE, YOU'RE GOING TO SAY THIS
IS EXTREMELY PREJUDICIAL.
BUT THERE'S NOT MUCH THEY CAN DO
ABOUT IT.
IF KYLE RITTENHOUSE GETS OFF ON
THIS, IF HE IS FOUND NOT GUILTY,
THEY CANNOT RETRY HIM.
IT'S INTERESTING.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS TO
REMEMBER IS WHY IS THIS EVEN
COMING UP, RIGHT?
RITTENHOUSE IS GOING TO SAY
SELF-DEFENSE.
I WAS SO AFRAID FROM ALL OF
THESE LOOTERS AND ARSONIST.
EVIDENCE 101 TELLS YOU THAT IS
NOT GOING TO FLY.
THAT'S WHY THIS EVIDENCE
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN LET IN.
WHETHER SOMEONE WAS SETTING FIRE
TO A BUILDING NEARBY SHOULD HAVE
NO BEARING ON WHETHER KYLE
RITTENHOUSE WAS IN FEAR FOR HIS
LIFE AND DECIDED TO SHOOT
PEOPLE.
THOSE TWO THINGS DON'T GO
TOGETHER.
THE JUDGE SAID POLICE TOLD
RITTENHOUSE AND OTHERS, WE
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS.
YOU CAN TELL THIS IS JUST GOING
TO BE FRAUGHT FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM.
AND JURY SELECTION BEGINS
MONDAY.
.
>> CAN'T BE CALLED ALLEGED
VICTIMS.
>> NOT EVEN DECEDENTS.
>> IT'S NOT EVEN ALLEGED LOOTER.
>> IT WILL CONFUSE THE JURY.
YOU ARE DEMONIZING THE PEOPLE
WHO DIED.
THEY WILL BE ARGUING ABOUT
WHETHER IN FACT, THEY ARE THEY
WERE LOOTERS OR RIOTERS.
IT WILL NOT FOCUS ON THE PERSON
ON TRIAL.